Last time, it was Cake Week.
Whoa!
After Ruby's shaky start...
Oh, you mucky pup.
..she fought back, earning
a Showstopper handshake.
I don't know why I give myself
so much things to do.
But it was Rahul who impressed
Prue and Paul the most...
That is a fantastic cake.
..winning Star Baker.
And it was Luke...
Oh, it's all just completely melted.
..who had to leave the tent.
Not my weekend, eh?
Now it's Bread Week...
I do like bread.
..with a classic
British Signature...
Come on, please! Please!
..a tasty takeaway Technical...
There's no good.
..and gigantic Showstoppers,
which will push the bakers...
Fingers crossed.
..to the limit.
The inside of me is just
like a pressure cooker.
It can burst any time.
For subtitling services, contatct:
waqas.zahoor89@gmail.com
Sandi, why didn't you say?
Say what?
That you're in pain?
This is a clear cry for help.
Don't worry - I am there for you.
Yeah, no, that's very kind...
No, don't say another word.
I'm going to get you a chair,
make you a salad. Thank you.
Actually, it's Bread Week
and I was going to give
a little talk about different
kinds of European bread.
This is the French word for bread...
Hey, Sandi, got you a chair.
Thanks. There you go.
I feel much better.
Of course you do.
You know why?
Because you and I communicate.
Yes...
For subtitling services, contatct:
waqas.zahoor89@gmail.com
I'm excited. It's Bread Week.
Bread's my thing,
so I really feel
the pressure to do well.
Paul is the expert on bread.
Nothing is going to slip past him,
so, yeah, it's a little bit scary.
I can already see his face,
poking and prodding away.
Oh, man, no, I'm not
going to think about it.
It'll be fine.
Last week didn't go
particularly well.
Not going to cry this week.
I hope I'm not going to cry.
Star Baker last week,
which was really good.
But I think every time you come back
here, just gives a little bit like,
oh, I'm going to feel sick.
Do the French make the best
bread in the world?
Yes, they do.
I mean, I think so.
Hello, bakers, and welcome
to the traditional theme
of week three, the one with
absolutely no pressure from Paul.
It's Bread Week.
Oh, dear!
I'm imagining it's going
to be handshakes all round.
Today, Paul and Prue would love
you to do your take
on the classic Chelsea bun.
You must produce 12 sweet buns
using any flavour,
filling or decoration
that you wish, but the buns
must be baked with
their sides touching.
They have to be presented
still attached so that Paul and Prue
can tear one off for judging.
That just doesn't sound right,
does it? Sounded violent.
OK, you've got three hours
for your Signature Challenge.
On your marks... Get set.
Bake!
We are back.
Absolute full energy.
We are going to be smashing
this Chelsea bun challenge.
I love eating bread. Loads of people
have turned their back
on bread recently. Not me.
I've always liked a Chelsea bun.
Growing up, definitely
one of my favourites.
Chelsea buns are made
with an enriched dough,
which has added milk,
butter and fats.
Rub in the butter,
rub in the butter.
These extra ingredients can slow
down the yeast, meaning a longer
proving time is needed
to achieve the necessary rise.
The interesting thing
about an enriched dough
is it's a really good test
of a baker's knowledge.
The dough is going to take longer
to rise, so not to panic
when nothing seems to be happening.
It will take longer.
It's a bit of a speciality of mine.
I want to see great flavour
combinations,
but it's all about the dough itself.
It must be beautiful and soft
with a great structure inside.
It pulls apart.
It's the classic tear and share.
Hoping for perfect buns,
Kim-Joy has an extra step
that should ensure her dough
rises to the occasion.
Morning, Kim-Joy. Hello, good
morning. Hello, Kim-Joy. Hello.
Tell us all about your Chelsea buns.
So, I am using the tangzhong
technique in my bread.
What is it? Explain.
It's like doing a roux.
You add it to the dough and it
helps it retain a bit more moisture,
so they'll be extra fluffy,
hopefully.
I've never used that method
before myself, so it's going
to be interesting to see
how they turn out.
Always experimenting
with new techniques, Kim-Joy likes
to surprise her boyfriend,
Nabil, at his comic shop,
with new creations.
Kim Bird! Thank you so much.
Kim-Joy's extra soft Chelsea buns
will be made with pistachio, lemon
and cardamom filling.
It feels nice being able to explain
something new to Paul about bread.
I feel a bit cheeky saying that.
Looks like this is done.
Kim-Joy isn't the only one making
additions to her dough mixture.
Some chai teabags.
Gives a bit more flavour
to the dough and it's yum.
When Manon's not working
as a software consultant,
she can be found relaxing at home
with her flatmate Charlotte,
who has the same taste in tea.
And pyjamas.
Manon's unique heart-shaped buns
will incorporate two
of her favourite fruits -
apricot and cranberry.
In France, we are very lucky to have
a bakery every five minutes' walk.
But since I'm in London,
it's quite harder to find bread.
No, it isn't.
According to a French person.
Yeah, according to a French person,
there isn't one on the doorstep.
The fact is you have baked more
bread since you've been in London.
Exactly. It's so satisfying.
It just comes out of the oven, it
smells delicious. Oh, I love it.
I'm doing a spiced orange
Chelsea bun.
I'm a little bit worried
that it's a little bit simple
on the flavours, but,
I mean, my kids like them.
That's got to count for something.
Just a little bit further, darling.
With two harsh critics
of his own at home, Dan is hoping
to impress the judges
with his classically flavoured
orange and spiced buns packed
with brandy-soaked sultanas.
How are you feeling?
I feel like my bread's pretty
average. Like, it's not...
It's all right, but then there's
Paul standing there looking at it.
He is the bread specialist.
He is. He's Captain Bread.
You can't pull one over on him,
can you?
No. He sleeps in a bap.
I'm kneading it now and I can feel
it starting to get quite elastic.
Kneading creates the gluten
responsible for giving bread
a good structure.
It's good exercise, this.
It's the only exercise I get.
Without enough kneading, the bakers'
buns will be dense and flat.
I'm just going to knead it
for one minute and 45 seconds more.
This is my time schedule,
so I've got to follow it.
Antony is taking
a more relaxed approach.
I'm going to let
the mixer do most of it.
Me and my partner,
we love to have
bacon and maple syrup and pancakes.
So I'm going for
a decadent breakfast bun.
Big foodies Antony and his partner
Gary are always experimenting
with flavour combinations
in the kitchen.
If filling his buns with a cinnamon
peanut butter wasn't indulgent
enough, he's also topping them
with a boozy caramel sauce.
That is, if everything adds up.
So you've got 11 and one in the
middle. Is that it?
Three in the middle,
and the rest on the outside.
Don't ask for the maths.
Can't do the maths.
Can't do the maths right now.
All right, then. OK.
Thank you anyway. Thank you.
You're a banker, right? I am! Shh!
Yeah. Can't do the maths.
Just saying. Anybody else?
It's no wonder we've
had a banking crisis.
It's just really trying
to stretch it out.
It's a good work-out, yeah.
Forever tinkering at home,
artistic Terry is a keen gardener,
potter and painter.
I'll be with you
in a second, Jack.
Hoping to make up for a wobbly last
week, Terry's going the extra mile
by using home-cured locally sourced
Amalfi lemons, chopped apricots,
dates and mixed peel.
Is bread your thing, Terry?
I love bread.
I'd like to say I thought
other things were my thing, but...
I just live by the day
in here, honestly.
I want to see you flourish
a little bit more.
This could be my week.
It's nice and squishy.
I think it's ready to prove.
We can rock and roll.
About 30 or 40 minutes.
I want it to double
in size, basically.
I'm hoping 25 minutes.
Oh, be good.
With their dough proving...
They're very nice mangoes now.
..the bakers face a race
against time...
Everyone loves my chopper.
..to get their fillings ready.
Can I put an order in now, Antony?
So, my Chelsea bun has got
an Indian twist on it this week.
The filling is called gajrela,
which is carrots boiled down in milk
and then I'll be going in
with some ghee
because it's not rich enough.
Always keen to step up
to a challenge,
fitness fanatic Ruby will add
vanilla and cinnamon
to her dough to complement
her sweet carrot filling.
My only worry is whether it will
restrict the rise of the dough.
So I'll make sure it's just quite
a thin layer, so I'll reduce
it down so it will become
a bit more of a mulch.
I don't think you should use
the word mulch, because last week
he said one of your bakes looked
like a forest floor.
I'm just saying. Thanks.
Paul, don't comment there.
I'd rather not...
So, the strawberries
have been soaking
in 25-year-old balsamic vinegar.
Me and my husband had strawberries
with balsamic
on our honeymoon in Florence.
When not finding culinary
inspiration on far-flung travels,
Briony can be found exploring
new bakes more locally in Bristol
with her mum Colleen.
Have a little bite. Go on.
Her attempt at a Tuscan masterpiece
will see her combine
raisins and pistachios,
before finishing with a finely
balanced balsamic glaze.
That's the youngest, yeah,
that's the baby. That's 12 years.
12! And that's 25.
What, and you're using
all different ages?
Because that one's really sweet.
Why, because it's older?
Yeah. They get sweeter as they get
older? They get sweeter. Yeah.
Wow, I'm learning so much
on this show.
It just goes in and then
as I walk home it goes out.
I still don't know what ganache is.
So, here's the marzipan.
And I get excited by colour.
I've always been a bit garish
and lacking taste.
Karen's love of colour
extends beyond the kitchen.
She can often be found creating
things for her friends and family
at home in Yorkshire.
For a Christmassy twist,
she'll be adding cranberries
to her textbook Bakewell flavours.
Oh, not again.
But it's my favourite.
I don't care.
You've done it every week!
But it's delicious.
It's getting boring now.
No, it's not. Are these two filling
you with confidence?
Absolutely. Excellent.
Bursting with confidence.
You do win Best Dressed.
That's all I'm saying.
And it's Bread Week
here in the tent,
we've come to an exciting moment.
Bakers, one hour gone,
two hours left.
Terrible tension.
Oh, yeah, he looks good. I mean,
I think he's doubled in size.
He looks big.
I'm just looking back.
It's always a bit terrifying
at this point,
but this is normally what it looks
like, so...
Loving my dough at the moment.
My Chelsea buns are called
Cardiff City versus Chelsea buns.
I don't mind about Paul and Prue.
I want Neil Warnock
to have one of these.
Jon spends his weekends cheering
on his beloved Bluebirds
with his mates.
He's hoping to soar into a league
of his own by giving
his salted caramel and pecan buns
an unusual topping.
You're putting marshmallow
on the top?
Yeah.
That sounds really disgusting.
Don't hold back, Prue. Yeah.
I do have quite a sweet tooth.
Oh! Get on there.
I am not using any wet fruit
or anything like that,
but the butter
keeps it really moist.
The more the butter, the better.
Right, let's roll it up, shall we?
All I'm thinking is getting
everything even across.
I do want a very, very tight circle.
Oh, that's going
to be really tricky.
Don't stick on me now.
Right...
Morning, Rahul. Hi, Rahul.
Don't sigh.
Hold your hand out.
It's shaking. It's always shaking.
What are you worried about?
So many things.
You're Star Baker!
Star Baker, for goodness' sake.
There's only one way to go
from there, though, isn't there?
Yeah, that's true.
That's the trouble.
Rahul moved to the UK
eight years ago...
Hello, guys.
..and now bakes regularly
to make new friends.
Look at that.
He'll be giving his classic
Chelsea bun dough an exotic kick,
with a sweet mango and cranberry
filling
flavoured with Bengali five spice.
I always use a thread so I'm
hoping that that will give me
a nice, sharp, clean cut.
It doesn't squash them down, which
can happen when you use a knife.
Although, saying that, I've just
realised how wonky that one is.
I don't know how much
they're going to spread and grow.
Hopefully, this is a good guess.
I am going to make them
a little heart shape.
Pretty happy with those,
although you never really know
until they've had
their second prove.
Do your thing. Please, be good.
Um...
I've made a complete mess.
Before I rolled my dough,
I should have sprinkled
this over the fruit,
and I haven't.
Absolute disaster.
This is not the way to do it.
It's whether they stay together
now...
Oh, my life.
As we were!
Look at the time!
Bakers, you only have one hour left.
Oh, God.
The bakers must manage
their time carefully.
What are you doing
for the next 25 minutes?
Stressing.
If they don't prove their dough
for long enough,
their buns will be too tight
and won't achieve the trademark
share and tear Paul has asked for.
Five more minutes?
Not five more minutes?
Is it going to over-prove?
Under-prove?
If the bakers prove them
for too long,
the buns will collapse.
I do not want them to go flat.
I need it to hurry up and rise.
So I need to get a move on.
Maybe wait a couple more minutes.
I don't know.
It's always a stressy moment.
My head's inside the prover
right now.
I can't think.
Breathe.
Just, like, when is the right time?
To take them out, to cook them.
I know.
They look ready. I don't know why
I'm second-guessing it.
Makes me nervous.
Paul's prowling around like a...
bear.
He can mess with your head,
can't he?
I can't ever tell
what he's thinking.
I think,
"Do you want to see my buns?"
OK, there you go.
Are you proved already?
God, they're massive!
They're going to get even
more massive in the oven.
Have you ever had it
where the middles explode upwards?
Oh, don't say that to me now.
I'm going to put them in the oven.
If I can get them out
of the proving bag.
I'll be back in a few days.
They're not very uniform.
But you don't start poking dough
about once it's proved.
What are you doing? Prodding.
I'm just opening
the swirl up a little bit.
Right, chucking them in. Really?
What do you mean, "Really?"
Don't get in my head.
Be well!
Bakers, you have half an hour left.
Half an hour.
Let's put the sign
of the cross and that's going in.
Do your best.
19 minutes.
Let's go.
They're on their way up.
The yeast just has that last burst
of energy, but then it dies.
It's dying right now.
But it's for a good cause.
Considering the disaster
of forgetting the sugar,
I think they've come out OK.
It might be the new way.
They've gone a little bit too poufy
in places, but they're big.
I think they're massive.
That's why they're taking
so much time to cook.
I'll just leave it. The more
I see it, the more I get stressed.
I'm hoping it bakes.
Stressed out again.
Bakers, you have five minutes left.
What?
Oh, come on.
Please, please!
Just need it to be about 92 degrees.
91.
92. I guess they're done, then.
Oh, my God, they never looked
like that at home.
I think I've cooked them
a little bit too much.
I'm just worried that Paul is going
to say it's a bit overbaked.
I'm quite pleased with it.
I think tangzhong is amazing.
This one's taking ages to bake.
Is that good or bad?
Terry behind me said
good things take a long time.
Yeah, but his are already out,
so... Yeah.
It is a big waiting game,
but it's worth it.
Bakers, you have one minute,
just one minute.
One minute.
This is my little bluebirds.
Gold spray.
So if nothing else,
it will be colourful.
I am happy with that.
I think they need
a little bit longer.
Considering the disaster
they could have been,
if they taste OK, I'll be happy.
They are going to say
it's messy again.
All right, let's do it.
One, two, three.
Oh, my God, it's very hot. Oh...
Done-zo.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Bakers, your time is up.
Please place your Chelsea buns
at the end of your benches.
Job's done.
Stop, Rahul. Yeah.
Don't make me come over there.
The bakers' Chelsea buns will now
face the judgment of Paul and Prue.
They look pretty even.
Mmm. Got a nice colour on them.
The tangzhong, it's going
to be interesting to see
how that affects the dough.
I think it's offered up
a very delicate dough.
It's quite soft,
which is good for Chelsea bun.
So I think your baking is very good.
Good. I like the flavours.
Is there citrus in there as well?
Yeah, a little bit.
That's the overriding flavour
that you get.
I think it's delicate and it needs
to be a little more obvious.
They're heart-shaped, aren't they?
Yes.
Very neat. Slightly over-baked.
The edge is definitely tough.
The flavour's fantastic.
The marzipan really works with
the fruit and the apricots as well.
The dough has got
a gorgeous structure.
If you'd brought it out
five, seven minutes earlier,
they would have been perfect. OK.
They're all even, got a nice colour.
They break apart neatly.
Absolutely delicious.
Really sticky on the outside.
Great orange bang of flavour.
Oh, really good. Dan...
Ah! It's perfect. Thank you.
It's annoyingly perfect.
And I'll tell you why.
Your structures are regular,
it's beautiful and soft.
Your interior has a good
overwhelming orange flavour
and even the decoration sits
on top beautifully.
Thank you.
It's a well-made Chelsea bun there.
Dan, we're in love with you.
Well done!
I think it looks impressive.
It's over-baked.
It shouldn't be crispy.
The structure's good.
Soft, but the outside is... is tough.
Mm.
The overall impression
is of dryness, which is such a pity
because the flavours,
once you swallow everything,
it's just fantastic.
One of the qualities of
peanut butter is it's very dry.
When you have a dough that's very
dry, what you're getting is dry.
Stop saying dry, everyone.
Everyone, stop saying dry.
Thanks, Noel!
I think they look like
the ones I make.
Looks lovely.
Tastes great.
The dough's beautiful and soft.
The sweetness is about right, too.
But spread the fruit more evenly
so you don't get these big gaps.
If you hit the filling,
it's perfect.
Thank you.
They look really pretty,
but they've exploded
a bit, haven't they?
They have, yeah.
It hasn't been folded properly
and neatly enough. Right, OK.
Lovely and light. Nice dough.
I think that's delicious. Oh, yay!
The flavour is very, very good.
It's a shame it looks the way
it does. Yeah, OK. Thank you.
Do you know, I think
it looks really pretty.
Lovely flavour. Good.
Structure's lovely. Yeah.
It is well-baked. Oh, good.
I love Bakewell, but I've had it
a few times from you now. Right.
The next bake you do, please don't
put any more. I was thinking,
you say a signature - isn't that
something you always take
everywhere you go? Mm.
Well, there you go!
Yeah, yeah. Thank you. Thank you.
Did you have sugar in your dough?
I didn't, but there was sugar
in the carrot mixture.
It's not enough. This feels hard.
It feels crusty. Right, OK. That's
not how a Chelsea bun should be.
I think that flavour's
very interesting but I think
it fundamentally lacks
that stickiness. Yeah.
Mixture in a Chelsea bun don't work.
OK.
WHISPERS: I'll have a word with him.
Yeah, have a word!
I do like what you've done.
It's quite impressive.
Looks nice and spongy.
I think it feels
slightly over-baked.
It's over-baked. It is? Mm.
It should be much softer
than that on the palate.
The flavour's absolutely delicious.
Yes, that's what I wanted.
I like the decoration,
but not on a Chelsea bun.
I'll put a Liver bird
on the next one. How's that?
I'm sorry about that
much fruit on the top.
Are you trying to match my jumper?
Well, it does look a bit messy.
Yeah. But I must say,
it looks delicious.
Pulls apart lovely.
It's very soft and gooey, which is
the way a Chelsea bun should be.
It's very interesting.
They're such savoury spices.
I mean, there's such a contrast
to the sweet fruit,
but I really like that.
It's baked to perfection.
I think the mango chutney
is stunning.
Very clever, Rahul. Right.
That's a very good Chelsea bun.
Thank you.
WHISPERS: You don't need to
apologise. You're great.
It's just me being me.
I just feel so scared all the time
that I just say sorry to them.
But that went OK, I guess.
Oh, my God, look! Pheasants!
Two... Two male pheasants?
I'm a little bit baffled,
to be honest.
Like, I really don't think bread is,
like, a strong point of mine
and he seemed to really like it.
Hollywood handshake?
That's the second one.
It's old hat!
It's got to be my best challenge
yet, and Paul said they look like
the ones he makes,
so that was a good.
There's more baking
in me yet, I think.
I am feeling a little too low
after dry, dry, dry, dry.
But we'll try smashing it back
for the Technical.
SANDI TOKSVIG: The bakers practised
for their first challenge,
but nothing can prepare them
for what lies ahead.
One of the shortest
Technical Challenges ever seen
in the Bake Off tent.
Well, it's bread week, so I don't
think that Prue got a look-in
when it came to setting this week's
Technical Challenge.
It is a Hollywood hurdle.
Any advice?
There's not much time
to complete this challenge,
so use your time wisely.
There you go.
Right, off you two pop.
For your Technical Challenge today,
Paul would love you to make a batch
of non-yeasted garlic naan breads.
So, the judges are looking for
eight naan breads.
They must be uniform in size
and brushed with garlic ghee.
You have one hour.
On your marks. Get set. Bake!
Right, naan breads...
I have absolutely no idea
what I'm doing.
One hour. Not long.
If nothing else,
it'll be over quickly.
I love naan breads.
I've baked them a few times but
I've never done one without yeast.
Naan breads are traditionally
made in a tandoor oven.
I've made naan bread once.
Hopefully, all my ancestors' souls
are helping me out here.
But today the judges
are asking the bakers
to use their grill instead.
I have grilled bread before.
I don't remember what I grilled,
but I have.
Paul, why have we got naan
for our technical bake?
I'm hoping to catch them out
with this.
This is a naan bread
using baking powder.
Traditionally, it would be yeast.
But they'll have to use their baking
knowledge because the kneading
and resting won't take as long
as it would with a yeasted dough.
What can go wrong?
With a dough that's quite wet,
it's going to be quite tricky
to get them all the same size.
Then they've got to grill them.
They've got to heat
that tray up properly.
If they put a cold naan under
the grill, they're going to be
spending at least five minutes,
maybe longer,
and the whole naan would dry out,
it'll be like a cracker.
If they're too thick,
they're not going to bake.
Lovely flavour. I never thought
you could do that with a grill.
You making the curry, then?
Absolutely!
First instruction for the naan -
make the dough.
Wow, it just says, "Make the dough."
That's it? Yeah, that's it.
Have I made naan? No!
I just go into the freezer
and chuck it into the toaster,
so... buzzing.
Reasonably happy with that.
I've made naan bread
the same as this. No yeast.
You just have to, like,
believe your instinct.
I have, like, almost zero
instinct on this one.
Oh, this is very wet, isn't it?
I hate kneading wet dough.
I'd normally cheat and put it in
the mixer, but there ain't no mixer.
Considering I was kneading dough
a few hours ago as well,
this is quite hard work.
It should be a little wet,
just enough to bring it together,
because naan breads are very soft.
Oh, the more I work it,
it just does not seem
to be getting any smoother.
I don't really know what to do
with non-yeasted dough!
Feeling quite relaxed at the minute.
Yeah, having decent comments
from the Signature Challenge
puts you in good stead.
It's coming together now.
A couple more of these.
I'm going to stop with mine.
Are you going to stop?
I'm going to stop.
THEY LAUGH
There you go.
That's the dough.
How long? I do not know.
Probably about four minutes
on this challenge.
I'm going to be leaving it to rest
for about 20 minutes,
until it's got a nice sponge to it.
Look at the state of it.
I don't even know what I'm doing.
Is there anything I can do for you?
I'll draw a cat
on your instructions. Could you?
That cat has got a filthy mouth.
That is a potty-mouthed cat.
"For the ghee, melt the butter
in a small pan over a low heat."
A lot of people say
it's unhealthy, but every Indian
will overdose on this stuff
because it oils their joints!
"Carefully skim the foam
as it rises to the surface."
Onto the garlic.
I love garlic.
To be honest, I'd put garlic
in my breakfast if I could.
Yeah. I do love my garlic.
I may not join you for that.
I've just taken the dough out.
It feels quite wet, but I think
it's meant to be a little bit wet.
The dough feels good.
I need to shape them
into eight individual naans.
25...
Close enough!
Have you had many Indian takeaways?
Yeah, I love naan bread. Because I,
surprisingly, haven't. What shape?
I'm going for a pitta bread shape.
Classic teardrop shape for my naan.
Like a sort of baggy skull.
That's it!
Freeze!
No, that's not it, keep going.
Mine look very tiny, I think.
So now...
"Heat the grill pan under the grill.
"Lay the dough on the hot grill pan
and bake."
I fry them at home,
but Paul's asked for the grill,
he gets the grill.
If the grill pan isn't hot enough...
I'm always a bit scared
of things like this.
..the naans will not have
the softly bubbled texture
that the judges are looking for.
I've got a hot grill pan.
It says to brush with ghee after
but I'm going to brush
before and after,
because I think that's what I'd do.
Right, just get them on.
Cook these one at a time.
They're going to have to go
four at a time but I don't know
if that's a bad idea and they're
going to just, like, explode.
I'm going in.
I don't really know how long
these things need to bake for.
If it's burning, it's done.
If it's not burnt,
you might be lucky.
I'm going to do a bit of a trial
on this first one.
I want relatively crispy outside
with a nice soft, doughy inside.
Absolutely no idea.
I'm going to come back to them
in two minutes.
I think it should just be about
four or five minutes.
Why are you on your knees?
Are you praying? I'm praying!
Come on, you bugger.
They're puffed up.
Oh! You've got bubbles.
I think that's quite good.
Erm, a bit too crispy for my taste,
but let's turn them over.
I need it to go much faster.
I'm going to give the other side
just a couple of seconds.
They're not very brown underneath.
Right, bakers,
you have 15 minutes left.
Just 15 minutes.
God in heaven!
OK, I think that's about done.
Oh, God, they look
totally different.
Well, I ain't got time
to mess around.
They'll have to come out.
He's well done.
Yeah, they look like naan breads.
Yeah, I'm happy.
I'd eat one.
Do you think they look like
something that you would like to
eat? Yes.
Is that the right answer?
You can say no!
I genuinely have no idea.
They could be all right.
They could be a disaster.
That one's a bit pale.
Second batch. Yes.
Trying to get two in at a time
at the moment because time is short.
I'm doing three at a time.
I think I'm going in with four
the next time.
We can do it!
It's going to be
really, really tight.
Calm down. You'll be fine.
Bakers, you have one minute left!
Let's just go. No time. Aaargh!
Absolute chaos.
It just needs a little bit longer.
HE SIGHS  Done.
I just need to make them
speed up browning.
Quick, quick, quick.
They are what they are.
Bakers, your time is up!
There's no good.
Indian food has never
stressed me so much!
What?
Please place your naan
behind your photograph.
Doesn't sound right.
That was a bit of a...
Wasn't it?
Paul and Prue are looking for
eight identical naan breads,
brushed with garlic ghee
and topped with coriander.
They have no idea
whose naan breads are whose.
Right, we'll start with these.
A bit inconsistent with
some of the colours.
The shapes are a bit odd as well.
This end is brick hard. Mm.
I'm not getting much garlic, either.
Now, someone's chosen to do...
Round ones.
Well, roundish ones.
They're all a variety
of different shapes.
Breaks well.
I love the way it tears into flakes.
The taste is good.
That is a lot of garlic.
It is.
Look at this one.
They're all similar in shape.
You can see it flakes.
Oh, I like the flaking.
Some of them are over-baked.
You look at that one,
it looks more like a pitta.
Interesting.
Now, we've got some strong colours
here again.
That one's raw and that one's black.
That sounds like someone
running out of time, doesn't it?
A bit thick, as well. Do you know,
even where they're thick,
that's quite nice bread.
These look great.
Oh, that looks fantastic.
They feel much softer.
That is very light.
It hasn't been under the grill long,
and yet it's been so hot
that you've got a good colour.
Good shape, good consistency,
good flavour.
Yeah, they're pretty good.
Very good.
A bit inconsistent in shape.
And size.
They're a bit thick as well.
Tastes OK. Mm.
These look very thick.
And very small.
Look at the size of them! Wow.
Flavour's good.
Now, these have got a nice colour.
They're nice and light.
That's undercooked on one side.
Yeah, it is.
It's a pity, that, because...
Not much garlic.
..it's nice bread, isn't it?
It's just more like a thick pitta.
Now, looking at these,
the inconsistency in the baking...
Oh, dear, look at that.
All the backs aren't cooked.
The hot plate
was very cold underneath.
Right, last one. OK.
They're all the same size.
Mm, that's a bit raw.
You see how wet that is?
It's not quite done.
The flavour's OK.
But they are thick. Not good.
Interesting.
Paul and Prue will now rank
the naan breads from worst to best.
In place number ten,
we have this one.
Oh, Kim-Joy, really undercooked
and pretty inedible, I'm afraid.
In ninth spot is this one.
A bit inconsistent.
It was very thick as well.
Eighth place, this one here.
Very heavy.
They're only baked on one side.
Not good.
Ruby's seventh.
Dan's sixth.
Karen is fifth.
Rahul is fourth, and Manon is third.
And then in second place...
..was this one.
They tasted wonderful.
They had lots of ghee on top,
and lots of garlic.
So in first place...
Yay! ..Terry.
The consistency was excellent.
It's the fact that
they're still soft.
You could taste the ghee.
It was beautifully done.
They're great naan breads.
Well done.
We're coming round to yours
for a takeaway.
I actually feel quite ecstatic.
I do like bread.
I'm getting to like it more!
That was a very quick hour.
You know, I was just really happy
I got eight naans out,
to be honest with you.
Never, ever, am I making
naan bread ever again.
At least I wasn't the worst Indian
in the room.
I'm not from the region
that makes naans.
We make rotis,
which is very different!
Well, Karen really pulled it back
last week, so that's my inspiration.
I can't go out in bread week.
It's not an option.
That's it!
So, the thing that pleased
me most yesterday
was that Terry did well,
cos I think he needed
a good day, didn't he? He did,
but he seemed almost shell-shocked
that he'd done so well.
So who's in line for star baker?
Dan's doing OK.
I mean, he came sixth in technical,
I think he did really well.
He got a handshake
again, didn't he? He did.
He did, he did really well.
And Rahul, for all his
protestations, "I'm sorry,
"it's terrible,"
has been doing really well.
And I think there's a big group
of people at the moment
in a little bit of trouble.
I'd say certainly Antony, Ruby,
Briony, I'd have to say Kim-Joy,
as well, for the first time.
So I want to know, Paul,
is there pressure on you when
it's bread week?
Yeah, of course there is.
Look, he's wearing black!
The godfather of bread!
Hello, lovely bakers,
welcome back to the tent.
For your Showstopper today, Paul
and Prue would love you to make
a tiered korovai.
I mean, who knows
what that even is?!
Well, it's a highly decorative,
enriched sweetbread, it's mainly
seen at Eastern European
festivities and celebrations.
You know, like weddings.
It stems from a pagan belief
in the magical properties
of grain, and...
Thanks, Wikipedia!
Your tiered korovai must have
at least three tiers, any shape.
They must be impressively
decorated to reflect
your chosen celebratory party.
You have five hours.
Wow, I've got time to write a novel.
I'm going to learn Spanish.
On your marks... Get set...
Bake!
All right.
I need to move quick, here,
because the time seems a lot,
but it's not. It's all go.
When I was reading about korovais,
it's made by, like, 12 women
over days and days.
So...
When you look at it in that way,
it's probably not enough time!
PAUL: We've had some
whopping challenges in the past,
but this is a big one.
This is a five-hour bread challenge.
I think the mixer is
struggling to cope with this.
Oh!
When you're dealing
in big lumps of dough,
it's about the baking times.
They're never gonna fit
all the dough in the oven
at the same time,
so they've got to think almost like
a professional of batch baking.
But they've got plenty of time
to bake them properly.
The great thing about a korovai
is that it is decorated
to within an inch of its life.
Traditionally, korovai decorations
are very symbolic, and I think
we should stick to that.
What we'd like is the decorations
to mean something to the bakers.
The bakers have got to produce
a great loaf that tastes good
and looks amazing.
I'm expecting korovai perfection.
The bakers' korovais must
have at least three tiers,
which can be any shape,
size or flavour.
I am adding some fleur d'oranger.
It's like orange blossom.
But the dough must be good enough
to earn its place centre stage
at their chosen party
or celebration.
Oh!
Six of our bakers, including Ruby,
have chosen the most
common celebration for
their korovai - a wedding.
Good morning, Ruby. Morning.
Hello, Ruby.
Tell us about your korovai, then.
What are you doing?
So my korovai is for my mum and dad.
They didn't have a wedding cake,
so this is in dedication to them.
Ruby's ambitious four-tiered korovai
will be packed with an apricot,
almond liquor and cherry filling.
Hoping to put herself back
in the running, she'll use a
highly intricate technique
to shape her bread.
Mine is actually shaped
as a couronne,
which in French means crown.
Yes. And my mum's a queen,
so it was quite
a fitting sentiment to her.
It's a lot to do, but you seem
to have worked it all out.
I think it's possible. Thank you.
Yeah, good luck, thank you.
I love that you called
your mum a queen. Thanks.
My mum's in Queen.
She's Brian May.
See you later. See you later.
I'm not even thinking
about whether it could be last time
I'm in the tent. It's been great.
I've just got to
make sure this is great.
Antony is taking his
wedding celebrations...
The feeling is adventure!
..to the extreme.
It's going to be a
wedding cake for my brother.
So my honeymoon gift to him
was an adventure trip
to the foothills of the Himalayas.
Wow!
Antony's ode to the mountains
will see him use chocolate
and orange flavours.
Perched on top will be his
brother and sister-in-law
as thrill-seeking doves about to
embark on a journey of a lifetime.
There's going to be a zipline
coming down, right from the top.
Hopefully it all works out.
That sounds amazing.
We can test it out using Sandi.
She'd be small enough to use it.
It's sticky, but that's good.
If the Himalayas weren't exotic
enough, Kim-Joy's wedding theme
is even further out there.
I am calling it a kit-ovai,
because it is about a wedding
of two cats.
Amazing.
More cats should be married.
It's Ruffles and Raffles.
Ruffles and Raffles.
Yeah!
Kim-Joy's marking her smitten
kittens' big day with
a cinnamon and cranberry korovai.
Ruffles and Raffles
will head up the party
with their guests around them.
I just want to get this
in the proving drawer first.
That's not going to work.
Well, that'll just rise
at room temperature.
Giant amounts of dough.
I'm making the dough in one batch.
It is a big ball of dough and, yeah,
it's a bit annoying I can't fit
it in the mixer, but at least
I've only got to do this once.
Having foregone a cake
at his own wedding,
Dan's going all out
with a ginormous bread,
flavoured with orange
and lemon zest
and finished off with
delicate hand-crafted roses.
This is just going to go and prove.
So decorations now.
Let's go, go, go.
A traditional korovai
is adorned with
hundreds of intricate
bread decorations.
Don't panic, just do it.
Which for our bakers means
only one thing - more dough.
This is a dead dough,
there's no use in this one.
When you're making
all of these intricate designs,
you don't want it to rise.
It needs to hold itself.
I am making my little doves.
They are just a
bit fiddly and painstaking.
The jewel of a wedding korovai
are the two lovebirds...
Very romantic little doves.
..representing the
newly married couple.
Obviously,
got two boys on top of mine.
This is gay bread.
Is that its tongue?
No, that's a beak.
Shouldn't it be that way, then?
I think it looks weird that way.
I thought they were turtles.
They look a bit like turtles.
I thought they were seals.
They look like seals.
Inspired by a pair of newlyweds
she met in France, Karen's making
a continental breakfast
wedding bread,
decorated with symbols
of the couple's honeymoon
around the country.
Just making my bunches of grapes.
The green is matcha tea.
When I was at home, I didn't
have the matcha tea, so I got some
mint sauce out of the cupboard.
But this is so beautiful.
Quite like doing this
kind of decoration.
This is like a roti dough.
So I remember when I was little,
my mum used to give me bread dough
when she was making roti to play
with, because I was never, like,
an outdoor kind of person.
No.
So I am kind of going back
to my childhood now.
Inspired by the first British summer
wedding he ever attended,
Rahul will decorate his bread
with an abundance of
flowers and garlands.
In my ideal world, I would probably
do a lot of decoration.
What is your ideal world, Rahul?
I actually thought, like,
I'm going to do like
200 pieces of decoration.
200 pieces?!
Less wedded to the marriage theme...
Cutting the dragon out of bread.
..Jon is celebrating
his first true love.
What I'm making is
a bara dathliad Dydd Dewi Sant,
which is a St David's Day
celebration bread.
Not content with an abundance
of Welsh themed decorations,
Jon the patriot will also be using
traditional Bara Brith flavours.
Even closer still to heart and home,
he's brought with him
an extra memento.
I plait my daughters' hair,
but I don't plait it very well.
It's really nice to have that
to look at while I'm doing this.
Bit of inspiration.
I've done this wrong,
haven't I, now?
MANON: This part of the decoration
is a Faberge-inspired korovai.
Faberge? Yeah.
It's inspired by my family tattoo.
My mum and dad, brother
and sister, we all have it.
Manon's colourful Showstopper
will be flavoured with
orange blossom, and boast ornate
latticework at the bottom.
She'll top it with
her very own Faberge egg.
Shaping an egg shape is difficult,
but my mum and dad have an
egg farm, so, I guess making
egg-shaped things
kind of runs in my blood.
It's a beaut.
While most of the bakers
will be adding decorations on top
of their bread, Briony is also
adding them into hers.
I'm about to turret...
Oh! Mmm. Is that a technical term?
Yes, yes, yes.
So I stick them inside the
baking tin, and then as the bread
does its second proof,
they embed right into the dough.
Hoping for a fairy tale ending
of her own, Briony's making
a happily ever after korovai
for Rapunzel,
complete with extensive plaiting.
So this is Rapunzel's hair,
one of many braids
that will be on the loaf.
Before the second prove, the bakers
must twist and shape their dough.
I'm going to do the small tier
first, and then the medium tier...
The more complicated the design,
the longer it will take.
You don't want to make it too basic
but, at the same time,
you don't want to
make it too complicated.
I'm not gonna plait it and all
that, I'm just gonna do a ring.
I've got to do the plait,
which isn't so easy
when you're dealing
with something so fricking long.
NOEL: Hoping his dough retains
its shape,
Terry's using a traditional method
to prove and bake his korovai tiers.
These little babies
are terracotta baking cloches.
Turned on the table myself at home.
You tend to get a
more uniform cook through.
That's the idea.
Green fingered Terry will create
a spring-themed korovai,
complete with decorative bees,
flower garlands and bows.
What are you doing now?
I'm just putting a snip through,
this was the wedding thing
of joining together.
Oh! And it also brings
your breads together.
I think that's really nice.
That's ready to go in.
Just a quick prove from now on.
Fire! Wow!
Is it possible we have too much time
on our hands, do you think?
Time!
Bakers, you are halfway
through your Showstopper Challenge!
What?!
Yes!
All right, then, let's get
cracking with this stuff.
With limited time...
Every second counts, now.
..and space...
Where to put them down?
The bakers face increasing stress.
Inside me is just like a pressure
cooker, can burst any time.
Sorry! Sorry! It's OK.
Sorry, love.
It's all right.
Top tier is on prove one,
bottom and middle, prove two.
Everything is everywhere.
You take one dough out,
one dough in.
You prove, you add the decoration.
A bit of a juggling act.
NOEL: With multiple tiers and
decorations still to be baked...
Just getting my dough ready, so once
the first one's finished I can go
straight into my second one.
..they must make the
crucial decision...
HE GROANS
..when to stop proving...
Right, let's get this bread in.
..and start baking.
Wowee, he has gone ginormous.
I'm OK, I think, but it's such
a big loaf I can't know
that till the judging.
It just feels a bit different.
Maybe the eggs are a bit bigger
than the one I used?
Nestle the cats in various places.
Some of them are grumpy.
Come on, out you drop.
Come on.
Never stuck before ever,
now it's stuck.
Dammit!
The decoration's gone, it's dropped.
It's so bad.
Come on, bread.
Don't let me down.
It'll be a good hour,
because it's a big beast.
Bye-bye. Good luck.
This is gonna go
on for about 45 minutes, I reckon.
Please bake well.
Because there's a lot of sugar
in there, it'll catch quite quickly.
I'm going to just see how it goes.
I'm not confident with anything
happening around my life,
so how can baking temperature
be different?
What has happened to my bread?
It's just not proved at all.
Panic stations, because I'm really,
really lacking for time now.
I'm gonna give it
another 15 minutes.
Should have been in the oven by now.
Oh, my goodness, look at the time!
Bakers, you have one hour left!
My breads are still not in!
Wow. You just have no idea
how that works, do you?
Oh, my God.
Running behind
on the decoration schedule.
You're a bit tight,
I need to loosen you up.
You're like a breadstick.
You're gonna snap.
I'm not sure you've made enough.
I actually haven't made enough.
You seriously haven't made enough!
I don't know where time's gone.
Right, going in.
Right until the final whistle,
I'll be baking that.
Got to start mucking on now.
Sign of the cross.
I'm getting the bread out now,
I'm pretty sure it's cooked.
OK, it's 90 degrees,
it's 90 degrees, I'm just going
to stop it there. Feels a little bit
heavy, I'm pretty sure
it's gonna be quite doughy.
This looks like a funeral wreath.
My funeral?
If you go home, I'm going to quit.
Pinkie promise? Pinkie promise!
Thanks.
This is the last tier.
They're both going in. They're in.
TIMER BEEPS
Right, let's make some more roses.
This is the banner -
"Just meowwied."
They're not gonna get divorced
in a couple of years, are they?
Well...
Cos that would be so sad.
Oh, no!
Bloody same again.
I've never had them
sticking before.
A little underdone,
let's hope it comes out soon.
Coming out. Where's my oven glove?
I don't think I'm gonna make it.
I don't think
I'm going to get it all out.
It's all stuck to the side.
How much time have we got?
Bakers, you have
ten minutes, just ten minutes.
Ten minutes. What can I do to
salvage this in ten minutes?
It's cooked.
It's just an assembly job now.
Where's the front?
Because obviously it's quite warm,
the dough will start to flatten.
Ah, that's hot.
Nothing's holding, yet.
A little bit wonky.
Shallower tiers
than I would've liked,
but I'm not gonna put it on,
it's burnt.
Pull it out and quickly
slap everything on.
I'm going to run.
I need to get a goddamn move on.
Are you getting
married to this cake?
It's better looking than my husband.
NOEL LAUGHS
Stick!
Come on, roses.
Oh, that's a clumsy job.
Pff!
This is just going
to collapse on me, innit?
Bakers, your time is up!
That is the five hours over.
Please place your Showstoppers
at the end of your benches.
Wow, yours is lovely, Rahul.
It's all it can be.
HE SIGHS
Sit, stay.
I really hope this holds!
That was ridiculous.
Ooh! No! Dropping, dropping.
Not too sure if it's gonna hold.
It's judgment time
for the bakers' korovais.
Kim-Joy, please bring up
your Showstopper.
Sure. Trust me? Yep.
I'm a bit of a klutz.
KIM-JOY CHUCKLES
I'm not sure you should've...
Should not have trusted him,
Kim-Joy.
This is a shotgun wedding, isn't it?
I mean, there are an awful lot of
kittens already.
THEY LAUGH
That's their friends. Oh, their
friends. They're their friends.
I think the bread looks incredible.
It's a lovely bit of
plait work as well.
And I think the cats are amazing.
It really is charming.
Right, let's have a look.
That looks lovely.
Quite like a hot cross bun,
isn't it?
It is, yeah. I think I'd have liked
a little more fruit in it.
And it's a little bit tight,
so it's a little bit cake-like.
Another half an hour proving that
would've been perfect.
Tastes good, though.
And it's certainly celebratory.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
We wanted a highly
decorative korovai.
That's it. And that's it.
It really is a Showstopper.
The detail of the swans
and the decorations are
just absolutely lovely.
I hope it tastes as good
as it looks.
Oh, look at that!
I like that texture. It's like
panettone. That's fantastic.
You can see the swirls of the dough.
The fruit in there is delicious,
and that orange tang...
You're a little genius, Rahul.
Thank you.
Well done, Rahul.
It's simple and effective.
The colour of the bakes
are consistent.
Dan, you must have spent
a long time on the decoration
and they are absolutely exquisite.
I think it's a lovely texture.
Beautifully baked, really is.
The structure that you've managed
to achieve is very brioche-like.
But it needs something else.
It needs fruit in there.
The flavour is not strong enough.
OK.
The attention to detail on
the decoration is spectacular,
particularly when you look
at the hearts,
the plaiting is very, very good.
Lots of filling.
I love the almond flavour.
Perfection.
I've made a lot of couronnes
in my time,
but the bake, that laces its way
through the fruit,
is to be applauded.
Thank you. That is absolutely
stunning.
I could eat the whole thing.
Oh... Thank you.
Great job, Ruby!
It's certainly colourful,
but it does look a bit clumsy.
I think what you've done is
you've put two very heavy breads
on top of a bread that's warm.
The whole thing's sunk in. Yeah.
I'm not happy with it at all,
to be honest.
It is a bit heavy where
it's squashed together.
You've got too much fruit in there.
The flavour of it's fantastic.
Thank you for that. I just think
the texture, the look,
the whole thing is an issue.
Bad luck, John. Thank you, John.
Not perfect. Thanks.
My goodness.
PRUE LAUGHS
I like the fact that
they're muted colours. Yes.
It's lovely. I think decoration's
incredible. It's intricate.
I do look at the colour of the bread
and wonder what it's like inside.
So do I, I have to say.
LAUGHTER
The bread's a bit doughy
in the middle.
You've had to give it that strong
colour to try and bake it
because it's under proved.
It's so disappointing,
because it looks so amazing.
It show-stops from the outside.
Bit of a stopper in the inside.
No problem. Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Just to add to the drama,
hoping these lovebirds
go down the zip line.
Oh!
It's simple but effective.
I worry about the colour of that and
it could be down to the chocolate.
And there are not really
many decorations.
Yeah, I did have a problem with
time management, unfortunately,
so couldn't get all my deco
on the cake.
It's a bit heavy. Oh! Not the word!
It's not proved enough.
And then it's over baked,
and you end up with a stodge.
Not your best, Antony.
It's not my best. Thank you, Antony.
Cheers, guys. Thank you so much.
Still smiling. Still smiling!
The decorations are amazing.
It's almost you concentrated
on that and lost the bread.
All the work that you did,
you can't see.
And actually, part of
the bread's been ripped off.
Did it get stuck on the tin?
It did, yes. Yeah.
The whole thing...
..is not baked. It's massively
under proved.
Oh.
But my goodness,
the flavour is lovely.
It's very citrusy and sweet.
Delicious.
How long was the first prove?
30 minutes. And the second one?
15. 15?
And then you baked it? Yeah.
That's where your problem is. It
should've been at least two hours.
The idea's sound enough,
but, unfortunately, not very well
executed. That's fair play.
Well, I love the Faberge egg on
the top and this lattice is lovely.
And I hope it tastes as good
as it looks.
You've managed to utilise the
dead dough together with the bread,
and it works as a package,
so well done.
Right, let's have a look.
The orange flower water
is too strong.
It's like bath bubbles.
Oh, no! Do you know what?
You're lacking salt.
And I think it's affected
the texture of the loaf as well.
The design is impeccable,
but I think everything inside
is wrong. It's OK. Thank you.
Thank you.
The slightly leaning Tower of Pisa.
It is, yeah.
It looks very basic.
But, you know what? I love the way
you've embedded the towers
in the dough. Thank you.
NOEL: Oh! Oh, bye, Prince.
He's dead now.
Yeah, a happy ending for Rapunzel.
PRUE: I think for
a celebration korovai,
it really needs more flavour
or fruit or something.
It is definitely under proved. OK.
It's so tight.
You needed about another half hour,
maybe longer.
NOEL: That was quite a tricky
Showstopper, wasn't it?
PAUL: A lot of them were underbaked
and underproofed, which is sad,
because five hours is a long time.
But I think there's a couple of
people in line for Star Baker.
Dan? He's our steady man, isn't he?
He is.
And Rahul, who thinks he can't do
anything,
but he's a really,
really good baker.
NOEL: I've never met anyone like
Rahul. He's like an enigma.
Jon certainly did not
have a good Showstopper.
Strange, because he did so well with
the technical. He came second.
And, likewise, when you're looking
at Terry, who won the technical,
he was doing quite well and his
Showstopper was terrible.
I cannot stop thinking
about the flavours of Ruby's.
Yet again, it seems to me
that she saved herself.
She was in serious trouble
coming into today,
but to smash it out of the park
again with that Showstopper...
You said "perfection." I know!
But, unfortunately,
it leaves a couple of people
who really let themselves
down today.
One was Briony. Overall, Briony
struggled over the three challenges.
Certainly Antony. Flavours didn't
work, texture wasn't good.
The zip line was good.
I think that's not enough
with the bread. No? No.
Well, bakers, what a bread-fuelled
weekend. Well done for surviving.
I've got the great job of announcing
this week's Star Baker.
It's someone that the judges thought
was fantastic throughout
and someone who showed a lot of
swagger in the Showstopper.
The Star Baker this week is...
..Rahul.
CHEERING AND APPLAUSE
SPEECH DROWNED BY APPLAUSE
So, that means I get
the horrible job.
I'm afraid we do have to say goodbye
to somebody
and that person is...
Come on. Just say it.
Antony.
I'm so sorry.
VOICEOVER: Too soon,
leaving too soon,
but I don't think I'll stop smiling
because, you know what,
this is, for me,
the best opportunity ever!
Come on, bring it in.
I've met some
of the most amazing people,
so I'm smiling
because this isn't sad.
These are just happy tears.
I'm leaving, but still happy tears,
yeah.
God.
Thank you so much.
PAUL: It's very sad,
because he's a good baker
and I'm sure he'll carry on baking.
But, unfortunately, in Bake Off,
you can't afford to have a bad week,
and Antony had to go.
It feels so surreal. I mean,
I still can't believe it.
I just keep pinching myself,
"Is it real?"
Now I think I can bake.
When he put his Showstopper down,
it really was a Showstopper,
it took your breath away.
And it's his birthday on Monday.
Is it? Yes!
That's another birthday present
for you, then.
Rahul is getting stronger
and stronger.
When you look at the Showstopper,
it was baked beautifully and
the flavours were all there, too.
He ticked every single box.
We've never had this before,
where someone's saved themselves
twice now in their Showstopper.
I'm like the cat with nine lives.
Oh, my God.
I need to get my act
together next week.
I cannot deal with that stress
again.
Next week...
Next step, next step, next step.
..it's desserts... We're going to
put cherries on top.
..with a rolling roulade signature.
Nice, little roll.
There's a risk of it cracking
all the time.
A tricky Technical Challenge...
Yes. It's not looking good.
..which breaks the mould. Why does
everyone know what these are?
And Showstoppers that reveal all.
This is as nerve-racking
as giving birth.
As the bakers try... It's carnage.
..and avoid a meltdown.
Angry.
Look at that!
APPLAUSE
Subtitles by Red Bee Media